if you've been eager to show off your
virtual muscles and sink your chainsaw
teeth into some locust then the weight
may be over sooner than originally
anticipated i'm dave and this is your
games 1 news update during a live stream
broadcast representatives for microsoft
confirmed that Gears of War for may
launch a little sooner than expected the
company announced the Xbox one game is
now slated for launch in fall 2016
previously the action game which was
officially announced at e3 last summer
was slated for holiday 2016 although if
you really can't wait to play then
you're in luck as Gears of War for beta
is scheduled to arrive this spring if
you bought Gears of War Ultimate Edition
that you can be among the 1 million
people who get to play first also during
the live stream it was revealed that
forty-five percent of the Ultimate
Edition players are new to the Gears of
War franchise this would theoretically
bode well for Gears of War for but note
that the ultimate edition was included
with the Xbox one black friday bundle
which Microsoft continues to sell for
more on the Gears of War franchise you
can read our interview with producer rod
fergusson all about gears of war
Ultimate Edition Gears of War for and
the future of the Gears of War franchise
so are you excited to relive emergence
day let us know in the comments section
below or you can find me on Twitter at
regular Dave and for all of your gears
of war news stay tuned d gamespot com